[Musique]
l'hôtel Marigold fonctionne
correctement depuis huit mois maintenant les gens
vont et viennent mais il y a eu un noyau d'
habitués depuis le début et Sonny
prend un noyau de rouleau tous les matins une
précaution des plus précieuses pour s'assurer que
personne n'est mort dans la nuit madame  .  Evelyn
Greenslade ici Douglas Ainslie ouais je suis
ici
mrs.  Madge Hardcastle ouais Norman
Cousins ​​et mademoiselle Carol Parr se sont levés ici
mrs.  Muriel Donnelly a été laissée
mesdames et messieurs, c'est le grand
gars que les chambres savent que Thanos a pitié de
ma terre, le temps de la vie en Inde, eh bien, c'est
à peu près un rêve jusqu'à présent, tous les
autres rêves, je pourrais vous aider, vous
devriez l'épouser.
je le veux parfois  il me semble que
la différence entre ce que nous voulons et
ce que nous craignons est la largeur d'un cil
je suis tellement désolé si tu me parlais
je ne sais pas pourquoi je te dis quoi que ce soit
car je suis plus vieux et plus sage 19 jours
pendant toute la durée de vie d'une guêpe, je
n'ai pas pu résister à l'occasion de revenir
et de visiter les vieilles ruines en ruine et de
voir comment l'hôtel se portait aussi bien que
vous
[Musique]